hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain the american drama thriller film
called us
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
it is 1896 in santa cruz addie is out
with her parents at a carnival at santa
cruz beach boardwalk
she looks around the carnival noticing
various activities going around her
her mother is going to the bathroom
while her father is playing a game
addie is left unattended so she wanders
off to look around
first she goes to a beach by the
carnival then she enters a fun house
the lights suddenly go out and eddie is
stuck in a house of mirrors
suddenly she encounters her doppelganger
cut to the present day a family of four
drives to santa cruz california
addie is now all grown up and is the
mother of two kids
zora and jason after hours of journey
they arrive at addie's childhood home in
santa cruz
at lunch gabe wilson her husband insists
on going to the santa cruz beach
boardwalk that night for fun
addie remembers to this day what that
night at the funhouse had done to her
she is haunted by memories of the
encounter in her recovery during which
she stopped speaking for a while
she doesn't want to go there again but
gabe successfully persuades her
the family then drives to the beach on
their way to the beach
they are having fun in their car zora
makes fun of jason's magic fire ring
at one point they witness paramedics
taking away a body of an old man
with blood on his chest as they arrive
at the beach
they meet their friends josh tyler kitty
tyler
and their twin daughters as the two
families are relaxing
jason goes to the bathroom while
returning he is shocked to see a man who
looks similar to the dead man they had
seen earlier
addie notices jason missing and gets
very scared
when she finally finds jason they decide
to return home
at night addie tells gabe about her
encounter with her doppelganger when she
was young
however gabe doesn't seem to believe her
as they talk
the lights go out suddenly jason arrives
and tells his parents about a family
standing in their driveway
they look through the window and see a
family of four standing there
zora comes out too addie freaks out and
calls the police
as gabe goes out to tell them to go away
but the family doesn't answer
and just stands there gabe takes a
baseball bat and goes out again
this time they start walking towards him
he feels threatened
so he comes inside and locks the doors
however
the people outside find a hidden key and
come inside
the family is surprised to notice that
the intruders are their doppelgangers
they corner the family in their own
living room threatening them with
scissors
they make them sit in front of them
jason's doppelganger is pluto who loves
fire
zora's double as a sadist named umbree
caves double as abraham
and the group leader seems to be at his
double named red she is the only one who
can speak
and has a guttural and raspy voice red
tells them that they are the wilson
family's shadow and are called the
tethered
the tethered share a soul with their
look-alike counterparts and have been
living as their shadows their whole life
but now they have come to untether
themselves
red tells them a story about a girl in
her shadow referring to herself and
addie
while addy ate good and warm food red
had to eat raw blooded rabbits
addie was given soft toys to play with
while red's toys were sharp and cold
addie met gabe her loving prince but red
had to marry abraham because he was
tethered to gabe
similarly addie gave birth to a loving
daughter zora but red gave birth to a
sadistic monster
humbry at last she says that addie had
doctors to operate on her and help her
birth
but red had to do it all herself red has
come to despise addie and her perfect
life
so they have come out of the shadows to
claim their life
after explaining red makes addie
handcuff herself to the table
abraham drags gave away to the other
room umbry chases zora through the
streets
while pluto forces jason to play with
him the intruder's plan is to separate
the wilsons
terrorize them and kill them pluto and
jason are playing with fire in a tiny
room
where jason sees pluto's scarred face
for the first time
zora is hunted down by umbri as she is
about to stab her with a pair of
scissors
a man stops her zoro runs away as umbry
stabs the man to death
meanwhile abraham hits gabe making him
go unconscious
he then puts him in a garbage bag and
into the boat gabe tears a tiny hole in
the bag and notices the baseball bat
beside abraham
the boat suddenly stops taking this
opportunity
gabe comes out of the bag and hits
abraham with a bat sending him into the
water
but as the boat starts moving gabe falls
in the water as well
gabe sees the boat stop and climbs on
top of it
just then abraham attacks him from
behind but he pushes him back to the
water and kills him
gabe then takes the boat towards the
house meanwhile
jason realizes that pluto mirrors his
actions he distracts pluto with his fire
ring and manages to run out and lock him
inside the room
red hears the noise she goes in and
unlocks the door for pluto
she looks around the house for jason
then she finds addie's old stuffed toy
and cuts its head off
addie is still cuffed to the table but
she notices a fireplace poker nearby
she manages to grab it and free herself
of the cuffs
she then finds jason and runs out of the
house they find zora in their driveway
gabe comes there with his boat at the
right time the family immediately gets
on and then manages to escape
elsewhere the tyler family is in their
home when kitty hears a noise
she tells josh to check what it is all
of a sudden their doppelgangers appear
and kill the family within seconds
just then the wilsons arrive there addie
asks josh's double for help
when he opens the door for her she
realizes that it isn't him
and hits him in the head with a
fireplace poker however
it does little to no harm to him others
from inside
drag addie in as well gabe and the kids
are outside when imposter josh walks
towards them
the kids run away as gabe runs in the
opposite direction to divert josh's
attention
the kids then go inside the house to
look for their mother
zora picks a golf club as a weapon as
they hear addie screaming from upstairs
they go up and see the twins dead bodies
lying on the floor
as the doppelganger twins play in the
background suddenly
one of them appears in front of zora she
hits her with the bat
making her fall down the railings next
they are attacked by the other twin
after a little fight zora kills her too
kitty's double is in the bedroom where
she has tied addie to the bed
meanwhile gabe runs to the boat and josh
follows him there
gabe then shoots josh with a flare gun
and attacks him to death
kitty sees gabe killing josh through the
window just then
sora attacks her from behind but kitty
dodges it
she's about to stab zora but jason saves
her by hitting kitty on her head
the wilsons sit in the living room and
try to comprehend the situation
the 911 lines are all busy they look at
the news and realize that this has been
happening all around the country
the news says that the doppelgangers are
coming out of the sewers with scissors
as weapons
they are mindlessly stabbing people to
death throughout the country
they see that the doubles are joining
hands to form a massive human chain
after they have killed their
counterparts it is as if they have been
planning this for months
since the whole country is an attack
addie decides to drive along the coast
and escape to mexico
as the family gets into the car humbry
appears in front of them
zora tries to hit her with the car but
umbridge jumps onto it
zora then stops the car abruptly sending
her flying into
a tree where she is impaled on a tree
branch the family then flees from the
scene
they see several dead bodies on their
way they are stopped by a car burning in
the middle of the road
jason's double pluto appears there addie
goes out to fight him while the others
stay in the car
soon jason realizes that this is
actually a trap
pluto intends to ignite the family's car
he tells everyone else to get out of it
before pluto can light the match jason
remembers that the doppelgangers mirror
their movements
so he starts walking backward this makes
pluto walk backward too
in the end pluto reaches the burning car
and burns to death himself
but just then red comes out of her
hiding and kidnaps jason
addie runs after them she sees the long
human chain of doppelganger standing
across the beach
she then reaches the place she had
entered all those years earlier
she walks around it and finds a door
that leads somewhere downstairs
a rabbit comes out of the door she goes
down and discovers a huge place
it looks like a secret establishment she
goes down an elevator and enters a huge
hallway with several rooms on either
side
many rabbits run around the hallway she
finds red in one of the rooms that
appear to be a classroom
the doppelganger human chain is drawn on
the board addie asks her where her son
is
but red starts blabbering about how they
are human as well
she then reveals the secret of their
existence red explains that the tethered
also called the shadows
are actually artificial beings created
by the government to control the
originals on the surface for their own
twisted purposes
the project aimed at creating clones
that were connected to the people
through their souls
the purpose of this project was to use
the clones to control people like
puppets all over america
but the experiments failed and the
tethered were abandoned underground for
generations
mindlessly mimicking the actions of
their counterparts and surviving on
rabbit meat
that night faith had brought red and
addie together
the other quickly realized that red was
different so they selected her as their
leader
they planned this for years they wanted
vengeance on their counterparts but more
than that they wanted to create a
statement of their existence
hence they decided to form the human
chain after addie's encounter with red
her parents had admitted her to a ballet
dance class
so red used to mimic addie and dance to
according to her
dancing was the reason that saved her
then they start to fight in the form of
ballet
red graciously dodges all of addy's
attacks she has the upper hand in the
fight
red runs through the hallways as addie
follows her with the fireplace poker in
her hand
their fight grows more and more intense
suddenly red leaps at addie with a pair
of scissors from behind
but before she can get her addie stabs
her with the fireplace poker
killing her as red is on the verge of
death she whistles the same tune addie
had heard the first time she met red
this agitates addie so she strangles red
with her handcuffs
and kills her maniacally she then finds
jason hiding inside a locker nearby
they both go outside and find gabe and
zora hiding inside an ambulance
the family then drives away in the same
ambulance as addy drives
we see the flashback of the night she
met red addie was face to face with red
red suddenly choked her unconscious she
had then dragged her down to her room
and handcuffed her to the bed
red changed into addy's clothes and took
her place in real life
that night addie's parents took home
their daughter's doppelganger
this explains why red is the only
tethered who could talk and thought
differently
leading the revolt red's voice is
damaged because her double choked her
damaging her larynx and making her voice
raspy and guttural
this also clarifies why addie as a child
wasn't able to talk after she was found
at the beach
shadows don't know how to speak over
time addie's shadow learns to speak and
becomes a regular
person capable of love and laughter and
forgets that she is a clone
the movie ends as we see a several miles
long human chain formed by the
doppelgangers
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel
out thank you for watching